le ministre pierre fatigués se pressent
le pas partout autour du monde d etat
annonce des plans de relance verte
articulé autour de l'électrification des
transports si le québec veut prendre sa
place dans l'industrie du véhicule
électrique
il doit prendre le virage maintenant
quand je pense qu'on a une chance de
mieux un joueur il compte attaqué sur
plusieurs fronts de l'exploitation du
minerai au recyclage des batteries en
passant par la fabrication de véhicules
commerciaux il annonce 15 millions de
dollars pour le développement d'engins
électriques et intelligent comme le
projet de tracteurs autonome delbecque
ya pas de moteur essence est pas de
moteur diésel l'epo d'hydraulique
le tracteur entièrement électrique est
conçu pour sarcler les chances de façon
autonome sans conducteur on a des
actionnaires de direction qui sont ici
donc quatre actionnaires de direction
qui permette la rotation des héros
chaque route indépendante et puis on a
aussi les moteurs du site qui font la
propulsion le projet a été développé
avec l'aide de l'institut du véhicule
innovante un savoir faire qui émergent
qui porte très connues y compris donc
c'est en faisant en faisant des projets
comme cela qu'on forme des gens à mieux
faire au delà des véhicules l'autre
grand volet du plan c'est le
développement de l'industrie de la
batterie le ministre est confiant qu'un
grand producteur de composantes
s'établir à très bientôt au québec et si
j'annonce ou d'ici six mois je te
convient
à l'heure actuelle les batteries
assemblée en amérique du nord sont
essentiellement fait deux composantes et
de matières premières importées d'asie
monsieur le manque de techno je préfère
acheter des composants tout faire en
amérique du nord qui dépendent des
marchés asiatiques
le ministre préfère laisser à l'ontario
la fabrication de voitures électriques
mais croit que le québec pourrait vendre
des pièces à son voisin en 2000 il ya
des bonnes personnes qui ont
d'excellentes connaissances le québec au
niveau électrique on est bon là dedans
le train est peut-être sortie de la gare
mais il n'est pas encore arrivé à
destination
ici hugo lavallée radio canada québec